rickshaws and trucks join the second day
of a civil disobedience campaign with
protesters blocking roads
by pretending their vehicles have broken
down this to stoke further disruption
ahead of another day of rallies
protesters in yangon parked in the
middle of streets again and then drove
off a road off
very slowly once we stop that operations
our revolution will be successful this
civil disobedience movement
is the way we can defeat the military
junta that's our way forward
we are creating the traffic because we
want to stop the government workers
who are getting our tax money from going
to the office
i want everyone to join us
in southern myanmar protesters gathered
out front of complexes run by foreign
companies
involved with international gas
pipelines in the genbaut area
they appealed to the companies to stop
doing business with the new military
government
and in mandalay they gathered in front
of a courthouse where hearings for two
officials connected to onsongsu's nld
party
took place as agenta continues its
campaign of arrest people in the capital
nepal
called for the release of suchi and
students who were detained here
earlier in the week
we relatives have waited in front of
jail every day for information about our
children but we get nothing
we aren't even allowed to get close to
the gate and the authorities keep
denying that they've detained our
children
the junta has also issued arrest
warrants for several celebrities who've
encouraged the strikes
hundreds of people have been detained
since the coup not only those
politically connected to aung
su chi scott heidler al jazeera